and we're excited to welcome brandi
carlile to the table so excited to
welcome you
you're playing forest hill stadium
friday night that's right we saw you
there in montana you actually drove a
camper
to montana why i was just trying to keep
it real and i knew
it was such a big deal to like return to
live music that i needed just a little
time alone with the stage so
you slept there the night before yeah
were you
nervous brandi were you nervous i was so
nervous gail i was so nervous
have you looked in the mirror you know
you are brandi carlisle yeah
i think i felt you're nervous yeah i
think at that moment i felt more like a
trout fisherman and i needed to sort of
fuse
the two together so i just wanted to
like sit
in the audience alone and just the night
before and just sort of be ready
what were you telling yourself in that
moment i was telling myself don't cry
because you won't be able to sing yeah
but still be vulnerable
for for the people because we're all
feeling vulnerable and we need this
together you know
yeah and you opened your mouth and the
words came out and then you felt what
was it like is it i was kidding when i
said is it like riding a bicycle but i
wonder
when you've been off for so long did it
instantly come back to you the
audience it did like i i really had to
give
it the emotional space that like i
haven't not
sang in front of people for that long
since i was eight years old
and so it was a really big life change
for me and
coming back did feel like riding a
bicycle but i couldn't have told you
that before i was like wasn't sure it
would
it wasn't sure we saw the video for
right on time your new song
which courtney cox your friend directed
yeah you said you actually sent out the
song to people and they sent treatments
back and you picked hers why
hers was just the best and and courtney
she didn't send a written
treatment she facetimed me and she acted
out the whole thing
and i was riveted yeah i was like that's
the song
you get it like i didn't even tell
anybody that that's what it was but
that's the song
but the look and everything when i saw
that i said oh brandi has another side
that we don't know about when i looked
at that video
and the song this is what i like about
your music it's the lyrics that you
write
it's the lyrics that you write in
addition to your voice are you a lyric
girl do you like is that who you
attached to yes i do yeah yeah you're
literally
right yes very much so very much so
brandi i do
and then you have the voice too to back
it up you know the voice to back
people people keep saying your your
fellow homies who are in this business
say
during this pandemic they either felt
more creative or they just felt totally
undone and were sort of paralyzed which
one was it for you
first nobody thought be this long i know
that well that's a thing
first paralyzed and in denial that it
was
taking as long as it did i kept calling
my managers and telling them to stop
telling people shows were canceled and
they were like honey
yeah but then i accepted it accepted
what was happening
um spiritually and got got creative
and then you finished you finished a
memoir yeah that is now a number was the
number one bestseller
yeah broken horses okay do you mind if
we mentioned the name of the memoir
was that hard to write because sometimes
when people write memoirs they have to
they dig in places they don't
necessarily want to go yeah
well it was pretty awesome i actually
recommend
that like anybody write their story
you'd be amazed at like how cathartic it
is to sort of chronologically mine
your life and the things that make you
who you are it really did a lot for me
as um as a mom and as a wife
to like understand so many of the
mechanisms that i've put in place and
make a decision about which ones to keep
and which ones to leave in the book
have you not thought of that before
sorry anthony you've not thought of that
before
i want to tell you i had but i hadn't
you know and i just turned 40 and
obviously that was
existential um you know
so it was all kind of a this has been a
pretty powerful
couple of years for me i'm sure for you
guys too we saw
in the in the in the piece in front of
this that that some of your great heroes
have become your great friends like
elton john
joni mitchell who is now a kennedy
center honoree
you you facetimed with her yesterday
yeah yeah we face time
she's so excited about it guys she's
she's pretty
profoundly moving and exciting and funny
person really funny how did it feel for
you to hear her name on that list
oh i just saw it and freaked out and and
they were like we were sworn to secrecy
oh i'm pretty excited tony mitchell's
funny
oh she's so funny oh yeah yeah and she's
always like the last one to speak so the
room will go through a whole thing and
then it'll get quiet for a second and
then
joanie will drop a one-liner on you that
just put you on your knees
and now that we're coming out of it
allegedly as long as people get vaccine
this delta variant is no joke what are
you most looking
forward to how hug in terms of
yes yeah
can i ask you a question about growing
up you were a backup singer for an elvis
impersonation
i know isn't that crazy yeah music has
antecedents of elvis in it like the
joker your producer
wanted you to channel a bit of elvis
late elvis oh yeah yeah dave cobb
loves elvis presley and it's elvis is in
my voice and everything because
of that background vocal thing also it's
like you really can't get a better
education in terms of background vocals
so that that's a big part of my music
and also
like sometimes it's hard for me to tell
the difference between elvis and roy
orbison yeah
yeah yeah it's a big influence there's a
lot of roy orbison in your voice yeah
yeah a lot of roy in there yeah but when
you were i didn't know that but that
wasn't that cool such a great little
nugget when you were the you knew it i
know
yeah because anthony knows he does the
sequence started
but when you were a backup singer for
the elvis guy were you thinking
i want to do that i actually want to be
in front singing
yeah i had a dream oh yeah because he
was actually really quite good he was
just so good at just shaking it and
getting up there and just being the
queen and getting all that attention
and i was like yeah i know that's right
i need to be right there
we um we saw in the did you also have a
you have a side project called the high
women with
marin morris natalie hamby amanda shires
you said when when you formed that group
in 2019 that it was less of a band and
more of a movement
i'm curious how you feel about the role
of women in country music is coming
along right now
i've really loved seeing um some of the
progress and there needs to be so
so so so much more yeah um i think that
the role of
women um in roots music
specifically needs to really be
addressed and platformed and everybody
has to make a really conscious effort
um to uh to that but also
i think that the role of people in color
and roots music
people of color music is is even a more
pivotal point in that
so much of all american ridge music
needs to be handed back to the
architects in a really big way and yeah
yeah we're looking at mickey guyton
who's
coming out with new music yeah spencer
britney spencer
joy a lot of profile yes yes
alison russell yola it's a big big year
yeah yeah so you like the direction it's
going though
i like the directions going in and um i
want to be a part of
that momentum and that and that uh you
know advocacy
we talked about you how's your family
dealt with the pandemic
well i mean you know my big girl she did
her first grade
she did it remotely that was tough to
watch um but also pretty inspiring to
watch her teacher
really inspired me two of whom she had
too this year and then
you know my little girl she don't know
what the heck's going on
we have new appreciation for teachers
but we always appreciate you brandi
carla i love
i love that you love the setup piece
that we did for you yes because when you
were looking at it you go guys this is
so good i wish my mom could see it
we'll make sure you get a link so you
can show it to your
[Laughter]
we'll make sure that happens thank you
randy carlos best of luck friday night
at
forest hills stadium here in new york
city it's great to see you thank you
brandy's memoir broken horses is on sale
now and she performs tomorrow as i said
at forest hills stadium here in new york
city